find the area and perimeter of the
polygon so let's start with the area
first so the area of this polygon
there's kind of two parts of this first
you have this part that's kind of
rectangular or it is rectangular this
part right over here and that area is
pretty straightforward it's just going
to be base times height so area is going
to be 8 times 4 8 times 4 for the
rectangular part and then we have this
triangular part up here so we have this
area up here and for a triangle the
area's base times height times 1/2 and
that actually makes a lot of sense
because if you just multiply base times
height you would get this entire area
you would get the area of that entire
rectangle and you see that the triangle
is exactly half of it if you took this
part of the triangle and you flipped it
over
you'd fill up that space if you took
this part of the triangle and you
flipped it over you'd fill up that space
so the triangles area is half of the
triangles base times the triangles
height so plus 1/2 times the triangles
base which is 8 inches times the
triangles height which is 4 inches and
so let's just calculate it this gives us
32 plus plus oh sorry it's not 8 times 4
I want to confuse you it's the triangles
height is 3/8 times 3 right there that's
the triangles height so once again let's
go back and calculate it so this is
going to be 32 plus plus 1/2 times 8 is
4 4 times 3 is 12 and so our area for
our shape is going to be 44 now let's do
the perimeter the perimeter we just have
to figure out what's the sum of the size
of a fence would we have to build if we
wanted to make it around the shape right
along the sides of the shape so the
perimeter the perimeter I'll just write
P for a perimeter it's going to be equal
to 8 plus 4 plus 5 Plus this 5 this edge
right over here
plus I didn't write that down so I have
to 5 Plus this 4 right over
here so you have 8 plus 4 is 12 12 plus
10 or 12 plus well I'll just go one step
at a time 12 plus 5 is 17 17 plus 5 is
22 22 plus 4 is 26 so the perimeter is
26 inches and let me get the unit's
right too because over here I'm
multiplying 8 set 8 inches by 4 inches
so you get square inches 8 inches by 3
inches so you get square inches again so
this is going to be square square inches
so area is 44 square inches perimeter is
26 inches and that makes sense because
this is a two dimensional measurement
it's measuring something in two
dimensional space so you get a two
dimensional unit this is a one
dimensional measurement it's only asking
you essentially how long would you have
what string have to be to go around this
thing and so that's why you get one
dimensional units